Gustin previous videos how rome became a
republic in 509 BCE but it's worth
noting and I've done this in other
videos that at that point Rome was not
this vast empire it was really just in
control of Rome itself but over the next
few hundred years it starts to expand
Rome is a militaristic society the Roman
legions start to exert its influence
over more and more of the surrounding
people on the Italian peninsula and we
keep going several hundred years until
we enter into the 3rd century BCE and
this is a map of what the what the
Mediterranean at least looks like
roughly as we enter into that 3rd
century BCE and you see even though that
Rome has now exerted its power over most
of the Italian peninsula right over here
it was not the dominant power in the
Mediterranean it was really the upstart
the the new and growing Empire there
were other significant empires you see
here the remnants of Alexander the
Great's Empire his successors each now
at their own significant Empire and in
particular Ptolemaic Egypt and Seleucid
Persia which had control over much of
the Middle East and the other empire
that you see here in blue was the
Carthaginian Empire and as we will see
in the 3rd and 2nd centuries BCE Rome
and Carthage are going to come at
loggerheads and Rome eventually is going
to overthrow Carthage as the dominant
the dominant Empire in the Mediterranean
but you can see in this map right over
your entering into the 3rd century BCE
Carthage that you see in blue was a
significant Empire so the question is is
who were these Carthaginians so the
answer is is that they were Phoenicians
and another answer is even the
Phoenicians did not call themselves
Phoenicians but to understand where all
of this came from we have to go back
5,000 years ago five thousand years
before roughly five thousand years
before now around 3,000 BCE where you
have the
these city-states like tire and sedan I
don't know if you can see those well let
me rewrite it that is tire
this is sedan now this map is obviously
a map of the third century BCE but if
you go back to when these cities were
founded in fact before they were laid
before they were I guess you could say
put under the influence of
Nebuchadnezzar and then a committed
Persia these were independent
city-states
and they're in they're actually existing
cities in modern-day Lebanon and in this
region then the leading cities were tire
in Sudan you had a group of people that
would later be known as the Phoenicians
and the Phoenicians were famous for many
things so they were famous as traders as
as as really shipbuilders and traders
and they colonized much of or large
segments of the coastline of the
Mediterranean and this is going back
thousands and thousands of years and
Carthage was one of those colonies it
was established in the 9th century this
is what modern-day historians believe
sometime between 846 and 813 BCE it was
it was a it was a Phoenician colony it
was set up as really a trading post for
the Tyrians right over here and the
reason why they're called Phoenicians
they didn't call themselves Phoenicians
these Phoenician people they were called
that by the Greeks and later the Romans
because they were famous for trading
their purple dye so they had their
purple dye which they got which was
derived from mo liske mucus that they
were able to that they were able to get
from the sea as gate as Great Sea
traders and shipbuilders so they have
this purple dye and the term for this
purple dye it was you it was related to
the word pannikin or Phoenicians and I
know I'm not pronouncing it well and so
the the Greeks and the Romans of the
time called them the Phoenician people
for their purple dye now Carthage
as we will see in probably the next
video Carthage has a series of wars with
Rome which are called the Punic Wars and
I've always wondered where does that
term Punic come from why isn't it called
the Carthaginian Wars or the Rome Roman
Carthaginian wars and that's because the
Carthaginians were referred to their
origins as coming from Phoenicia and the
Latin term for that was pona 'kiss once
again related to the Greek word for that
purple dye so pentakus became Punic and
so the idea of Phoenician phonation
Venetian these are all related words to
each other so when we're talking about
the panic we're talking about the Punic
Wars these are the Romans or this is the
modern-day English the Romans would have
said Poe NICUs the these wars are
referring to the wars with Carthage who
are descendant from the Phoenicians now
just as a side note another thing that
you might be wondering about is hey this
word Phoenician it looks it looks it
looks familiar it looks like phonetic
like the phonetic alphabet and that was
the other famous contribution of the
Phoenicians is that our alphabet the
idea of our alphabet was derived from
the fennec from the phonetic alphabet of
the Phoenicians so the Phoenicians did
many many many things they settled much
they were one of the real naval powers
of the Mediterranean going back
thousands and thousands of years by the
time we get to the middle Roman Republic
we're in the 3rd century BCE we're in
the 200s BCE the the ancient cities of
tyre and sidon they're not part of the
Seleucid Empire the Seleucid Empire was
one of the successor empires of
Alexander the Great's
but their offspring so to speak Carthage
is now a dominant power in the
Mediterranean and with Rome starting to
exert its might although it has very
powerful armies it does not at this
point have a very powerful Navy but as
we will see as we get to 264 BCE these
two great powers in the Mediterranean
start to come into a little bit of
conflict
good